good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack Van
Horn from the University of Virginia and I'm
very proud to welcome you to this edition of our
2022-2023 foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series this lecture series is supported by
uva's integrated translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA brain Institute the College of
Arts and Sciences the school of data science and
through a grant from the National Institutes
of General Medical Sciences since 2016 the
foundations of biomedical data science seminar
Series has focused on the use of data science
methodologies artificial intelligence deep
learning and statistical modeling as they
pertain to different themes in the biomedical and
Health Sciences this year's theme is data science
in the public health consequences of the covid-19
pandemic where each Friday we enjoy presentations
from leading thinkers about the issues the
promise opportunities and hurdles associated
with understanding the secondary health effects
of covet 19. these include but are not limited
to delayed Health checkups treatments mental
health drug abuse increased obesity and the long
lingering health effects associated with the SARS
covid-19 virus participation participants excuse
me for our selected biomedical data science
innovative Asian lab program will leverage
these presentations as vital material for our
culminating in-person Grant project development
Workshop to be held at the lodge at St Edwards
Park in Seattle Washington in June of 2023.
today I'm delighted to welcome our speaker Madoff
moraf from The biocomplexity Institute at the
University of Virginia he is a 2023 bdsil mentor
and he is a distinguished professor in bioplexity
and the director of the division of network system
science and advanced Computing division at The
biocomplexity Institute here at UVA and also a
professor in the department of computer science
here at UVA he earned his bachelor's degree from
the Indian Institute of Technology in Madras he
earned his PhD at the University of Albany where
he earned a doctor of philosophy in computer
science and his research interests are in network
science sustainable habitats AI foundations of
computing and high performance Computing over the
last 20 years his division has supported several
federal and state authorities in their efforts
to respond to a number of problems arising in the
context of National Security sustainability
and pandemic science including the coveted
teen pandemic and before joining UVA he held
positions at Virginia Tech and at the Los Alamos
National Laboratory he's a fellow of the IEEE
the ACM the s-i-a-m and the aaas in continuing
with our 2022-2023 biomedical data science seminar
series theme today's lecture is entitled advancing
the practice of transdisciplinary Team science
research responding to the covid-19 pandemic
in his talk a Mata will be arguing that pandemics
are a complex system problem that are intricately
tied to the social behavioral political and
economic issues that go beyond human health
he will give an overview of the state of the art
in real-time computational epidemiology then used
in covid-19 as an Exemplar he will describe how
scalable Computing Ai and data science can play
an important role in advancing real-time epidemic
science as always we are streaming this lecture
live and for recording via YouTube and so if you
are joining us via YouTube thank you so much also
our specially selected 2022-2023 biomedical
data science Innovation lab participants and
alumni are encouraged to submit any questions
via the chat feature in their Zoom sessions I
will synthesize these questions and ask them
on your behalf during the last 10 minutes or
so of the lecture and with that welcome Madoff
we are so excited to hear from you today thank
you so much Jack for such a kind introduction
and thanks to you and your team members for
inviting me to this uh rather unique and amazing
opportunity so I hope I can do justice uh to you
uh to you in in terms of the program that you're
set up and I'm very excited about the topic that
I'm going to talk today so I hope you can all see
my slides uh let me first thank my colleagues and
my team members before I get into the details of
the presentation as you can imagine the the theme
today is team science and certainly is something
that we have practiced a whole lot uh the work I'm
going to present certainly is done by a large
group of folks in fact I've I've already said
many times in other talks that my contribution to
the overall scientific part is becoming smaller
and smaller as the team becomes larger and they
become really good at knowing these things I also
want to thank our funding agencies who have been
so kind in supporting us during the last few years
by the way of references I've included some here
of course I'm available to talk to any of you
folks later on um you know you can send an email
to me Jack and others have my email but these
references should help you uh you know sort of get
more details of the things I'm going to talk about
so a brief background about ourselves the the
bio complexity Institute and my division very
broadly speaking the division is focused on the
problems of massively interacting Network systems
and we intend to develop the foundations
and engineering principles that can help
us design such systems analyze such systems
optimize our systems and reason about them
and I'm when I mean large I mean systems between
10 to the 4 to 10 to the about 16 agents or
entities they are not so large that you can apply
statistical physics like principles and they're
not so small that you can really do it with a
paper and pencil like exercise and we are focused
in in our division on real world societal networks
uh not so much the physical networks themselves
so what are the kinds of questions that a group
undertakes here are just two of them we have been
very interested in coming up with methods um to
understand how we could support the development
of sustainable and adaptive social habitats and of
course today's theme and I'll go through this in
much more detail is how can we detect respond and
reduce the impact of the next pandemic outbreak
so of course these problems are so large that
it's it's impossible for a single person or
even a single Professor with a few students to
tackle them so as a result our group here has
taken a transdisciplinary team science approach
a TTS in short and focuses on building you know
novel tools and decision support systems to to
address these complex systems problems and as
Jack mentioned you will see as I go along that
pandemics are a excellent example example of
this these kinds of problems that require
a transdisciplinary team science approach
so just so that all of us are on the same page
uh what's transitionally team science or TTS I've
taken these definitions from a series of papers
I've provided references to them uh in particular
Cara Hall star talk on this was excellent uh
there is also an article in nature some time back
but TTS refers to a process in which collection
of individuals with expertise in different fields
work together over extended periods by
synthesizing and extending discipline
specific theories and Concepts to create new
approaches and methods address a common problem
and this should be contrasted with other terms
which are seemingly close but not same I found
this particular graphic rather telling I must say
which tries to articulate what team science and
transdisciplinary team science might mean so they
show an Apple for a unidisciplinary team effort
which is a researcher from a single discipline
uh working you know perhaps with their students
or a few other professors maybe in the same
Department a multi-disciplinary approach is one
where different disciplines work sequentially each
from their own discipline specific perspective
with the goal of eventually combining results to
address a common problem and a nice analogy in
this particular setting is a is a basket of fruits
so from a single fruit to a basket of fruits then
they go on to talk about interdisciplinarity which
is where different disciplines work jointly to
address a common problem some integration of
perspective occurs but contributions remain
anchored in their own discipline and I think
fruit salad is is their analogy for this which
I found quite telling again and finally they
make a a smoothie or a shake with all these
fruits merged together and that's how they capture
transdisciplinary science and we have defined this
upfront in the previous slide so I think from a
single fruit to a fruit shake is maybe a good way
to understand moving from a single discipline
to a transdisciplinary team science approach
so our group has practiced this for a long time
now in fact I joined the core group here when I
joined Los Alamos as a postdoctoral fellow back
in 1994 and I've then slowly become more more
senior person in the group and others have joined
in the meantime but this group has sort of stayed
together the core team has stayed together
for a long time and I've tried to uh sort
of capture the basic elements uh of our approach
the first is to have a common goal or a mission
second is to have a sustained and stable funding
from divorce agencies which seems not so important
but when you think about it becomes very critical
because if you have a project that lasts for a
year two years usually you don't have the time
to do something that is so Broad and in depth
that you can build such such an approach third is
to nurture a culture of diversity and respect I
think it's rather important to do that diversity
in all forms is is important for a project like
this to be successful we have found that it works
best to grow these teams bottom up now that is
not necessarily the case but in our particular
setting that turned out to be the best way to do
it we have most folks joining us as post-doctoral
fellows our graduate students and then they grow
through the ranks and this has allowed us to train
them and essentially uh engage them in a group in
a deeper sense and finally we work very closely
with policy makers and end users and stakeholders
of course you know uh PTS poses certain challenges
and I wanted to highlight a few of them here I'm
sure that you folks as you start working in your
Fields uh have experienced some of these issues
uh but and they're not only specific to TTS
but certainly they come come out and and show
up in a much much more graphic way in a certain
sense one is conceptual and scientific challenge
which is that it's hard for people to come
together when they don't have a Common Language
it takes a long time for people to be able to
talk to each other using a Common Language or
framework and and that's important because once
you do that you can really start exchanging ideas
in a more meaningful way cultural variation
among team members this is you know variation
in terms of what how science and engineering
is practiced within their disciplines so social
science department usually cares and and queries
about different questions and approaches then a
typical computer science department for instance
and those cultural differences have important
implications again once the team gets built
out this these variations sort of mend together
management and Leadership challenges and
finally incentive recognition evaluation
you know a simple question that I can pose for
all of you is uh who gets the credit for the
work who is the lead author these questions are
important in in a typical academic setting but we
have been able to overcome them and I think it's
doable in my opinion by setting this team right
and maybe that is one of the things that we've
done somewhat well where we've been able to keep
this basic team together for such a long time
so I'm going to for the rest of the talk focus
on a very particular complex systems problem
pandemics and hopefully in during the course
of explaining the things we have done highlight
the team science and transistibility team science
questions that have come back Jack I'm happy
to take questions of course from from the
individuals uh if they if they occur so let them
you can go ahead and ask them as they go along
so um there's a beautiful article by Feinberg
and Wilson after the during actually the H1N1
pandemic they they titled it is an editorial
article in science title epidemic science and
real time I encourage all of you take a look at
it beautifully written and they have highlighted
and and suggested five or six different questions
that we all might want to study and turns out that
these questions actually are very very relevant or
were relevant during the covet pandem 19 pandemic
as well so our team has been building modeling
tools and decision support systems to try and
and help decision makers as they responded to
the covid-19 pandemic and we wanted our models
to go beyond simple Notions of predictive uh
use we intended to build our models uh to First
synthesize available data to produce a consistent
and meaningful representation to provide a range
of interpretations of incoming measurements to
evaluate a range of response actions and behaviors
to monitor effective intervention strategies
to help coordinate understanding among diverse
stakeholders and ensure that these models are
used by analysts and not just by Computing experts
furthermore as the picture of the right shows
is a typical textbook view of about a pandemic
is and it evolves there's a Time series of
number of cases potential number of deaths
or hospitalizations during uh during a pandemic
you start fairly small and it grows has a peak
and then comes down and there are various faces in
this pandemic there's initial phase which is the
investigation followed by recognition initiation
acceleration then it slows down in preparation for
the next round this is actually a picture that we
had in our paper that we wrote in the early phase
of the pandemic but what is interesting is the
real pandemic looks very very different right so
this is how covid-19 pandemic looks like you have
at least four if not five waves just in the US so
if you combine other countries this story becomes
even more complicated what is perhaps even more
interesting is that each wave had different sort
of features in terms of its shape in terms of its
peak uh who got infected but also the underlying
cause of reasons in the first wave largely we
had lack of immunity mixing in the population was
fairly High during the initial phase followed by
extreme restrictions in terms of lockdowns the
second wave people relax social interventions
followed by holidays University openings and
behavioral adaptations the Third Way which is
a Delta wave which hit some countries especially
hard and even in the US some parts of us harder
we had relaxed the social intervention by then
vaccines had come in so you saw a very different
spread and you can see on the map the third
map on the right shows you the impact of the
Delta wave which was very very spatially diverse
in its form and finally June 22 where you saw
the Omicron wave which was very large and I can
continue on this thing the waves have continued
but this this example for two years the first two
years of pandemic really captures how different
pandemics are from what a typical textbook might
think about and it actually affects the kinds of
tools and models we might end up making so in our
group we started working on this problem in about
March of 2020 to some extent we were lucky we
have been working on developing academic modeling
tools from about 2001 or so so in some ways we
were ready but as you will see throughout the
presentation we had to constantly reinvent what
we were doing adapt ourselves and really work to
answer the relevant questions that this particular
pandemic Post in some ways as my colleague says
oftentimes we found out and most other groups
found out that their tools were good to solve
yesterday's problem so every problem posed a
new set of challenges and I'll come to that
80 of us got together and have been working on it
consistently over the last three years now believe
it or not and folks have very very different
background I've given a list of department or you
know expertise that people have in in the group
we've also uh diversity in terms of uh gender in
terms of uh backgrounds in terms of universities
and institutions and and so on so forth
the group has supported a number of federal
and state and local authorities including
HHS Department of Defense CDC
Department of Health here in Virginia
the Virginia hospital and Healthcare Association
the local universities NSF and NIH and hopefully
as I go along you will you will see how the story
unfolds I've given a particular website here that
contains most of our presentations and and papers
we have written close to 85 papers in the last
three years on topic related to the covid-19
response and we have also done more than 120
presentations to various agencies and I'll talk
about it more Brian Lewis has been an excellent
individual in terms of doing these presentations
week after week to the state so what sort of
models do people use then to study pandemics right
there are three class of models broadly speaking
of course this is a simplification but hopefully
capture the basic idea the first class of models
are what I call data driven or statistical model
these models really don't try to understand the
underlying it's a causal basis for why a pandemic
might happen they're just trying to understand
this from a correlational standpoint people
have used this quite effectively in forecasting
in terms of Niche modeling where you just look
at occurrences you build a simple model train
it using either statistical methods or more
recent machine learning techniques and then
use to understand potential uh occurrence or
diseases across across a region of Interest
there is another class of models called the
compartmental mass action models this model set
of models have been extremely popular and the book
by Anderson May which is seminal book in this area
describes this model in great detail um and was
developed in early 1900s and has been the Mainstay
of epidemiologists mathematical epidemiologists
who try and study how epidemics might evolve in
time and the basic idea actually is is motivated
by models in physics in chemistry in economics
and they are called compartmental mass action
models you divide the population of interest
in say three groups here you don't have to have
three the number of groups that you use depend
on the problem that you study here the simple
model is s i and r s stands for susceptible I
for infected are for recovered and then you write
a set of differential equations which tell you
the rate of change of the concentration of these
these compartments following pretty much a print
set of principles that you might come across in
chemistry when you do chemistry or physics where
you have a rate of change of of the concentrations
think of this you know in the simplest form of
chemicals and molecules right now in some ways
the Simplicity of these models has been very
valuable uh as you can see the very very simple
model to State it's very transparent and as I
said has been the Mainstay of of com mathematical
epidemiologists for a long time over 100 years and
even during covid-19 was effectively used because
you can quickly build it you can explain it to
folks and you can use it to make certain decisions
there's another class of models that we have been
building called agent-based models they're also
called networked epidemiology or network-based
models which use causal theories as well as data
to essentially build these models out and they're
a little different than the previous model one of
the perceived weaknesses of ODS or compartmental
models is that there's a huge amount of symmetry
that is assumed in the models right there are just
three compartments so every individual essentially
who is in state s looks identical but we know that
is not the case people have different demographics
different disease States different levels of
immunity different levels of interconnectivity
between other individuals where they go what
they do what sort of Behavioral responses they
might have all these things are different but
sir models due to the Simplicity are it's not
easy to capture these diverse diverse aspects
a network based model is much better better you
hear you have a node or a agent per person in the
population you have an edge between two people
if they are in Social proximity of each other
and then you have a way to transmit the disease
from an individual who is susceptible is infected
to an individual who is susceptible so here for
instance initially in the node B naught might
be the infected individual and might pass the
disease on to one of its neighbors V1 V2 and V
or V3 and the disease might continue I've given
a pictorial representation here this is picked
up from a paper that we wrote during the Ebola
crisis because we've also wanted to highlight
the nurses and and their interaction with with you
know ecological uh elements that they are part of
so what are the challenges that these models might
face I'll highlight these challenges I bought six
of them but these challenges will also allow us
to appreciate the approach we have taken and the
role of Team science that comes out very very
clearly so the first challenge is the Computing
and data challenge as you all know very it's very
hard to get real world data to drive your models
it was especially so even during covet 19. now I
must say that during covid-19 the amount of data
that was made available was substantially more
than the previous epidemic outbreaks and previous
uh you know infectious disease outbreak studies
that we had all done it's quite amazing how the
the community got together to do this but even
so data was relatively sparse and this affects
the kinds of models you can make furthermore
the issue about privacy uh digital contact
tracing apps became available but were not used
as much in the US although other countries they
were used much much more Computing became a
big issue getting access to large Computing
systems and storage systems that can be used
consistently became harder and harder to get
foreign is a modeling challenge here I want to
highlight that the models that one needs to build
have multiple scales in them there is a spatial
uh scale in terms of the size of space that
you want to model the social interaction
scale which is from an individual household
to a community to a county perhaps to a state
and to a country and then you have a temporal
scale you know you want to understand the
progression of disease within an individual
and then you also want to understand the
transmission between individuals behavioral
changes that have occurred from hours to days
to weeks and control measures they take a long
time to Institute and then take time to pull off
pull back so you need uh multi-theory multi-scale
multi-level representation of the system to be
able to capture these these uh scales effectively
third is a challenge that that arise from
understanding ecological and biological aspects
relate to viral Evolution immune responses
zoonosis and vaccine development in testing
these questions become very Central you all
know that covid-19 there's a there was a lot
of debate of how the disease essentially jumped
into humans the current belief is that it jumped
into humans in in China some people challenge it
I still think that's the right right hypothesis
but usually that sort of a jump happens right
now there is a genuine concern uh you know not
serious concern but a concern about H5 and
you know in one style potential pandemic
you know we have seen this play out in words
and in minks in in Denmark and other places
a third challenge has to do with validation
and uncertainty quantification so in physics
It's relatively straightforward what one means by
validation they are well understood theoretical
principles and people typically use predictive
or retrospective well you know validity to either
make sure that you can reproduce a phenomena
or you can predict a phenomena now those are
are good ways to validate models here but they
are not the only ways in fact it's rather hard
to only use those as metrics for validation
structural validation model turns out to be
an important part of it and this is an open
area in many ways it's something that we all
are still learning how we you know use data to
try and validate these models in the real world
another challenge that is somewhat unique perhaps
for you folks is what I'll call decision making
challenge so on the left I've shown your typical
what's called UDA Loop uh basically where uh one
understands how models are basically formed and
decisions are taken at an individual level but
think about what really happens in the real world
every person effectively is a decision maker but
they're decent makers of various sorts uh I've
just shown three kinds of decision makers citizens
themselves so a person or a person who is the
head of a family might make decisions on behalf
of the family in terms of sending kids to school
deciding to go to work or not wearing masks or not
we have decision making that happens at the state
and local Authority level and then decided making
that happens at the level of say individual nurses
doctors Educators uh the point being each of them
needs to look at the system from their lens and
needs to contact specific information to make that
decision and these decisions are localized and
their actions are also localized in in most cases
the next challenge is communicating scientific
reserve and this turned out to be very challenging
as you all know covid-19 caused a fair amount of
social and political debate in our in our country
and outside our country between countries as well
so on one hand you want to talk and tell people in
the best possible way what these results May
meant but you need to be thoughtful about it
and we'll again discuss it a little bit in my
talk another challenge was of coordination one
needs to do coordination at various levels
of echelon so to say at the level of say
managing the pandemic within the University of
Virginia that's what the president's job would
be for the University but you have to manage
this pandemic and the level of a county at
the level of a state across various states in
the U.S across various countries and within
U.S across various agencies you know between
Department of Defense who had a very different
set of consideration to CDC to NIH to FDA and
so on so forth so that hopefully sets the stage
for all the challenges one faces in building out
models of this this guy now let me take the next
um about 10 minutes or so to try and tell you
how we build out models in our lab to support
decision making and it's a rather unique approach
uh it's it's an approach that is rooted in AI
uh real world data and high performance
Computing and theoretical computer science
so the approach we take can be broken down into
roughly the following elements about four of
them in the first part we take all the available
data that we have to try and build a digital twin
of a region of Interest so you might will
take information about the census we'll
take information about how people might move
using either trip Diaries or information about
their movement from mobile phones to the extent
that is available in in a you know manner that
is anonymous we take information about built
infrastructure we take information about the
actions people take and activities people take and
fuse this data using fairly interesting machine
learning techniques to build what I would call
a virtual social contact Network so if I want
to study Charlottesville as my object of uh
study in terms of the epidemic then I would
build a virtual Charlottesville in this you would
have every individual resident of Charlottesville
represented the family is represented houses and
the building locations represented and people
would go out doing their normative activities
during the day in this virtual representation
the key part is is that the locations are real
but individuals are synthetic they are virtual
but they satisfy a rather important property
if you look at the senses of our population
then it resembles the senses of Charlottesville
but if you look at a particular address you might
not find or in fact you would almost never find
except for accidental reasons uh family which is
identical and we want to do it because we want to
preserve privacy and anonymity of individuals and
the goal is after all to come with normative
actions not really specific directives for
a family or an individual so that's how this is
this kind of network is made out this is a social
contact Network where as we discussed individuals
and nodes and edges represent social contacts here
I've shown a bipartite graph representation of
it we take then this information and make what
we call Live digital print and the idea is what
we have is the representation of the system at
the start of the pandemic but that needs to be
continuously evolved updated using ground data
these details of the evolving disease model
case data serology data interventions that
are going on uh information about policies
information about vaccine schedules vaccine
Supply information about uh you know economic
impact that's happening closures that are
happening all this information is fed into the
digital twin to make it live effectively ready
to use simulations to project forward or do case
analysis so once this Live digital twin is made we
used high performance Computing based simulations
agent-based simulations to study how the disease
would spread to the pop you know through this
social contact Network what we did during the
course of this pandemic is uh and I didn't say it
here but essentially built out the social contact
Network for all of us so there are 300 million
nodes or and about 10 to 12 billion edges in this
graph very very massive data structures built
out and so we needed high performance Computing
simulations to really run uh you know disease
progressions through this virtual U.S and as I
said one single machine really would not even do
the job so we have access A specialized and uh and
a good access to a big high performance Computing
cluster here at UVA but that was not enough we had
to actually use two big supercomputers one in at
Pittsburgh called the bridges two and another one
at Anvil at Purdue spelling is wrong I'll fix it
but and well at Purdue uh was also used to do this
work and the interesting part was that we want
to do this so that these machines act seamlessly
to give you a sense of the amount of data that
is produced and used to run these simulations
a typical case study would involve 2500
simulation instances for calibration and about
10 000 simulation instances for projections we
are 3100 U.S counties 500 Days of the simulation
going forward it reduced about 20 Gigabytes
of synthetic data to start the simulation and
would produce about 1.5 billion entries or four
gigabytes of aggregate output data four terabytes
of individual level output data so that you could
then analyze the output data to derive meaningful
insights and on the right I've shown a typical
workflow that the team underwent week after week
to try and run these models where you start build
out these models updated at the start of the week
and then you turn back and come up with reasonable
predictions and assessments at the end of one or
two weeks depending on the question so let me
tell you how we used these complex models that
we built uh over a period of time and I want to
First highlight that the work was done to support
operational response for State local and
federal agencies in real time during an
evolving pandemic and it's important to
understand what all these words might mean
from a real-time perspective our goal was to try
and build test and complete the tasks that were
driven by a strict deadline it was not very useful
to say that we could not do it in the time that
the decision makers wanted the results right you
might as well not do it there to be operational
which means the problems were derived from the
current needs and not made by us and the resulting
analysis should be useful to the decision makers
as well results need not be perfect as a result
because the time was a constraint and this is an
art to figure out what is a good balance between
the scientific rigor that you might be able to
achieve in the short time but still a meaningful
result that the policy makers might use and the
models can then be improved over time as we go
along and it last but very importantly this was an
evolving pandemic which means that the questions
that we were posed but constantly changing and
as a result the data that we had to ingest had
to constantly be updated the models had to be
developed essentially every time the new question
came out and software systems had to be developed
to try and capture these models and finally wide
range of analytics and Document Preparation had
to be done to support this just to give you a
sense for how the pandemic Evolution changed the
questions that we were posed by the policy makers
here is a a small subset of the kinds of things
we we really were engaged in back in March 2020
um we were actually studying very simple questions
that related to importation of disease to the U.S
will U.S get get infections in and once it
was known what were the first few hot spots
once we reached fall of March 2020 we were asked
to study questions related to vaccine allocation
um we continued that problem to understand fair
and optimal allocation we then moved the questions
about risks of new and emerging variants in
April 2021 it was clear from outbreaks in
India that Delta might cause a lot of trouble in
June we moved to impacts of and risks of vaccine
hesitancy in npis by that time we had been able
to successfully vaccinate a lot of people but we
found that we're starting to slow down certain
people were very hesitant to take vaccines
we then moved on to planning for evolving strains
which has become an important and ongoing issue we
move to then understanding the impact of waning
immunity the first set of vaccine doses that
started to wane so people's immunity had started
to wane as a result uh we then start to understand
the impact of vaccinating 5 to 11 year olds if you
remember September that was a question in October
the question moved to understanding user boosters
then we moved to the Omicron wave in January 2022
actually about November 2022 afterwards we
studied bivalent booster uptake moved on to
impact of variant severity and immune escape and
we continue with the same questions and try to
understand now intimacy of this potential disease
so you can see that each time a very different set
of questions came out to try and help the policy
makers and this is just one part of the story
um that we had to study so I have a more sort
of interesting thing for a single problem like
vaccine allocation that goes to a similar part
but I'll quickly sort of go through it because
of time and just say that just the question of
allocating vaccines turns out to be a rather uh
complex problem and here I've shown you how the
problem changes from a very simple theoretical
question on the left where it is stated as given
a budget of K vaccine you want to allocate them
most effectively all the way down to vaccine
nationalism coupling the vaccine contagion with
hesitancy understanding the Notions of fairness
and Equity understanding the role of new variants
and understanding the roles of noise and complete
information in trying to do this allocation
so a group actually over this three-year
period has built more than half a dozen
um decision support apps dashboards that
were driven by the models we made here are
four examples that I have shown one is built
on use of Mobility data this was done with
our colleagues at Stanford and Cloud our state
agencies to figure out the impact of you know
essentially closing down certain kinds of
locations maybe maybe Gems or you know stores
or work locations or religious practice you
know locations the second one which has been
operational from the very beginning and is very
similar to the JHU dashboard that many of you
might know at the New York Times dashboard is
about basically doing assessment you know just
capturing the cases across the world and this
has been a very very useful tool we built it
very early on with them along the same time that
they did it um and has been continued continually
used by a lot of people I think over a million
hits for this particular dashboard we also built
another dashboard for our state and then scale
it up nationally to try and provide individuals
unless and policy maker a sense of the demand
and the medical resources so you know how many
people uh are admitted to the hospital what the
occupancy might look like over a period of time
um so that hospitals could be better prepared
in terms of uh you know the utility that they
can provide to the response strategies and finally
we have a vaccine vaccination statistics dashboard
to understand how the hesitancy was evolving
over a period of time uh in in our in our state
thank you made a number of advances I'll probably
skip this but just to let you know that we had to
build out these tools almost none of the results
that I talked about had ready-made tools that were
existing to solve the problems we had to really
work essentially to build out brand new systems
to try and address them let me give you three
examples and then we'll go to the last part of
the talk and end we work very closely with our
department of health here and the governor's
office and other departments Department of
Education Department of Homeland Security in our
state Brian Lewis has said that multiple of you
know briefings essentially at least one briefing
every every week uh Andrew Warren did additional
briefings later on and others did it as needed
and we solved multiple problems for the state
as was requested uh from questions related to
vaccine distribution allocation to contact tracing
to questions rate to quarantining and testing uh
one of the big success stories for us was advising
our state not to build field hospitals and as we
understand this saved our state you know anywhere
between 40 and 100 million dollars because if you
recall in about May 2020 New York was going
through a terrible period in the covid-19
pandemic and they had actually built Javit Center
as a field Hospital they'd also gotten this Navy
ship to help them uh and the question was whether
we need to do something similar to get prepared in
our state luckily our model suggested that we
might not see that bigger uh outbreak here at
that point of time and as a result field hospitals
will not need furthermore we are also able to tell
them that to the extent we build hospitals in the
future we should build them as smaller units that
are mobile so that you know they can move from one
place to another and not be placed in one place
and not be able to move we've also supported
the CDC scenario modeling work for over now
two and a half years or so this is an important
uh Consortium uh Johns Hopkins and NIH and CDC
leads it but essentially about nine
or ten teams have come together and
the teams with working closely with CDC and other
federal and state officials come up with scenarios
so this is not about forecasting but really trying
to understand what what would happen if certain
set of you know situations play out and this was
used for vaccine allocations for kids it was used
for the very early mmwr report that was briefed to
the president it was also used by CD senior cities
officials and has been used throughout these uh
throughout the pandemic you can go and take a look
at the website that is maintained and captures
we are on the 18th scenario 18th round roughly
takes about a month for one scenario to play out
and then is used by the officials as appropriate
we also support the scenario the forecasting
of the CDC and and UMass Amherst and CMU ran
many more teams participate in this us was one
of the few teams that provided Ensemble models
uh and over the period of this this pandemic
and we're the few teams that provided models
at the resolution of a single County so every
week we would forecast for the next four weeks
how the pandemic would look like for each of
three thousand counties in the U.S a beautiful
example of how you make real-time models to try
and drive this these kind of systems and the
models did quite well we had a couple of new ideas
uh one was phase driven Ensemble modeling one was
using transfer intro pistol methods to try and
understand correlations between various signals
so this hopefully gives you a sense for the
diversity of you know problems the diversity
of teams that might have come together a sense
of real-time and operational requirements that
were posed to make genuine real world impact
on the class problem that we were studying so
I want to end in next three minutes by describing
where we are heading one we actually over act for
a long period of time now the group has built
out as a part of nih-funded proposal a system
called bvbrc it used to be called Patrick before
but the reason to bring it up now is that's being
significantly extended uh to try and make a
resource center where bioinformatic tools and
genomic information is being made available for
researchers across the country and in fact across
the world very widely used resource which is
now being extended significantly uh 18 plus
years of continuous funding 600 000 page views a
month uh 9 million viral genomes stored on this
and during covid-19 this played a very important
role uh in terms of people doing genomic analysis
we recently in October got a new Grant as a part
of the pathology genomic centers of excellence
there are five such centers that were awarded
across the country we were one of them dcls in
the state leads it in addition uh to dcls UVA uh
your BCU and vdh are part of the team at UVA our
Institute as well as the group led by Amy Mathers
our integral part of this this uh Center and the
goal is the realization Steps From the realization
that we really don't have a seamless setting right
now in the country where genomic information can
be collected essentially as the pandemic evolves
and that can be used to drive surveillance and
potential interventions so these five centers are
supposed to be able to collect analyze genomic
data for you know ongoing sort of diseases but
also new outbreaks that might occur uh you know
for instance for a while monkey pox was important
um you know there might be a new AMR style
outbreak in our hospitals here Nitro or maybe
there is another Outbreak on h5n1 that might
happen and the idea is to be able to collect it
and link all these data sets across so that we can
do meaningful studies between uh between various
groups my sense is that this is just the start
of the CDC program we expect many more states
to participate in this and really become much
broader National resource over a period of time
um and the last part I want to bring up is is a
a Viewpoint that I have on where we are likely to
go with building out models like this and I think
that we need analytical tools and distance support
tools wherein individuals are supported and not
just typical individuals in sense of a governor or
a president of a university right in my opinion
and the opinion of our group every person is
essentially a decent maker and so the idea we
have proposed is a concept of P cubed Analytics
where the first P stands for pervasive axis which
is that every decent maker should be able to make
a decision at any place any time and on using
any device this idea of Mark Wise and computer
science called pervasive computing from where I
derived this notion of pervasive listen making
it should be personalized so the information
and analytics that the president of a university
needs is different than a head of the household
and it's different from a doctor who is working
at UVA for instance and is different from the
Secretary of health and so on so forth and
finally the decision maker should have fairly
precise information in space-time and context so
I think P cubed analytics are going to be Central
to the story this to sort of put this into play
we are currently supporting a rather interesting
challenge set up by the White House it's called
the pets price challenge it's a joint challenge
between the US and UK the part of President
Biden's democracy initiative and the idea is to
build privacy preserving tools to enhance uh you
know the you know use of of data for social good
and there are two data sets that teams are using
one is from from banking industry to understand
fraud in in Banks into you know inter-country
fraud and the second data set is provided
by our group based on the work I described
before where we have simulated the pandemic
in Virginia and in UK as a whole country and
we have individuals trying to build uh tools
to try and understand how data can be shared
and systems that can be built by in a privacy
preserving manner there's a beautiful area in
computer science called Federated learning that
is developing which uses deep learning along
with idea of privacy preserving learning to
advance it so with that I will stop Jack I hope
this was useful for you all thank you once more
for inviting me to this wonderful meeting Mata
thank you so much for sharing all that with us
um it was really impressive to hear about you
know the the amount of kind of computation
and modeling and kind of updating the models
in your scenarios and forecasting techniques
you mentioned that you had to leverage several
different high performance Computing systems
um how did you manage to get them all working
together so flawlessly to be able to do things
like that you that you described yeah so
uh I will admit that it was not Flawless
Midnight Oil was burned but um we we were lucky
for one thing because we have been developing
HPC models and very early on we saw that Rivera
for all its Trends is not going to be enough to
do these things so we approached NSF NSF is a
program called exceeds and there was actually
a Consortium of of companies and institutions that
came together doe NSF Google Amazon that provided
the folks who wanted Computing Cycles but we need
a very specific class of cycles and our colleagues
at the Pittsburgh super Computing Center were very
kind to support us so give you a sense for the
first six months the big machine at Pittsburgh 30
000 core machine was reserved for this competition
every night from eight o'clock in the night to
eight o'clock in the morning now after about
six months they could not afford to do that it was
you know others were waiting to use a machine too
even that machine turned out to be not enough
for us and so we then requested more access
through the Purdue super Computing Center the
interesting part is that we built out this what
I would call a spider-like system where we don't
have to access each of the machines separately we
essentially build a common queuing system where
you would set up the jobs and the spider would
essentially figure out where we have currently
available cycles and use them more effectively
and that was part of our garden Bell challenge you
know where we were finalists in in a competition
and showed that you can actually build a cloud
of supercomputers if you want to call it that
that's that's cool and I'm sure that it
wasn't completely Flawless I'm sure there
was some some uh things you had to contend
with but it's exciting to see that kind of
thing come together the notion of digital twins
is still kind of a relatively New Concept uh at
least only in the last few years have I heard
a lot about it so it might be just new to me
but it's interesting can you tell us a little
bit about what you know about the history of
that idea and the creation of these kind of
simulated almost like a virtual in you know
version of say Charlottesville for example
or any other place what's the history of that
um it's a really nice question Jack you asked so
the term digital twin was is coined relatively
recently but and I think it doesn't do justice
to exactly what's happening there's a earlier
term that we had used called synthetic information
system that I think also captures the basic idea
very similarly and interestingly the basic idea
of synthetic systems was in my mind uh studied in
statistical science in back in 50s and there's
a paper by Ruben and others that talk about it
now the current term digital twin really came from
engineering Sciences because they were trying to
study for instance an airplane or a building uh
and they were trying to represent it digitally
with all the details when you took out talk about
social systems and systems at the scale of a city
uh the kind of representation they're talking
about is not adequate in fact you would I would
argue that is no single representation of
the social contact Network for Charlotte's
Web so you have to merge multiple data sets and
build a synthetic representation that looks like
Charlotte's work and that's been our approach
we started doing this believe it or not back in
1994 there's a very very important paper by my
colleague dick Beckman and his friends at Los
alvos that started building synthetic populations
uh back in 94. for a project that was quite
different was an urban transport planning where we
wanted to understand how traffic jams emerge and
Chris Barrett who who is the head of the Institute
here was the pi of that of that important project
called transims and he he really had this Vision
that we want if you want to understand traffic
you need to build traffic bottom up if you
want to call it that and that requires us to
build digital representation of cities so it's a
relatively the old concept but the availability
of data and the ability of tools has made this
concept evolve rather rapidly and actually the
acceptance of it has become much much more clearer
I did not discuss it here Jack but an important
use of this potentially going forward is to train
deep learning models you know a lot of people are
developing tools for autonomous cars and vehicles
and Microsoft is ingesting large amounts of data
to essentially train these autonomous you know
cars but they're realizing that measuring data
constantly in the field is only one part of it
so they're starting to build simulations that are
realistic enough that can then be used to train
these autonomous cars in the in the computer first
you know from a data science perspective covid
was sort of a data windfall in a sense right as
we had so you pointed this out there was just so
much data coming and it was really unprecedented
and one of the things which I think resulted from
that is because there was so much you know the
fire hose of data was just opened up that what the
public saw was really science being done in real
time sometimes it was wrong or maybe it was not
as accurate as it could be and that kind of put
a little dent in the public trust in some of
the the forecasting some of the modeling how
bad the pandemic was going to be where it was
going to be bad all those things I'm curious
if you have any thoughts from your perspective
on how we can better ensure that we maintain
public trust in models like the ones you're
describing again a really important question
um I'm sure my answer is um not going to be
complete because this is an evolving discussion
um but I think first thing in
uh in a complex system like this
people have to be essentially educated to
learn that the notion of ground truth is
quite different if you want to take analogy of
of uh weather which is something people use a lot
I think we can all agree that if we predict a
number let's say 70 in in Charlottesville the
temperatures it tomorrow then either that number
would occur or not occur and we can measure it
with fair amount of precision uh I don't think
so such precise measurements are straightforward
at all in a pandemic like setting when we
want to estimate cases but I would like to
highlight a few other challenges just from
a context of forecasting in some ways Jack
one is and this this actually is rather important
and I would take it sort of in in order if you
want to understand forecasting of physical systems
like planetary motions in general we understand it
very well the system is deterministic at least for
the time scales we look at and as a result you can
see that you know we are able to predict things
really well you know people have gotten used to it
during weather forecast people understand that
their uncertainty but largely it is fair to say
that our Behavior does not play a role in how
the weather evolves at least in the short run
climate of course so much of the issue has to
do with measurements and to do with more and
more precise physical models pandemics and other
social systems like economics and markets have
this rather important part where our behavior is
an endogenous aspect of the system so if you do a
forecast looking at the forecast we might actually
change our Behavior and that behavior in turn
changes the outcomes so just because a forecasting
tool predicted a certain number two weeks from now
and that number didn't occur it is hard to easy
to discern whether that happened because it could
have happened and people change their behavior or
the models were fundamentally just wrong right so
this co-evolution of individual behavior and
adaptation along with the disease Dynamics I
think makes this problem rather non-trivial
and interesting so as a result a typical way
of evaluating is is hard and so this this aspect
has to be explained to individuals better we as
epidemiologists and modelers have to do better
as well in terms of not not uh essentially
overselling our work yeah you know as you you
can imagine that happened to some extent too uh
everybody became modeler a lot of people claimed
their models were doing very very well uh but one
has to be much more humble about it and and point
out the weaknesses that these models might have
warm it up thank you so much for sharing
your work with us this is really important
I love the big dateness of it the use of high
performance Computing and I I love the you know
the the caution that you provide us with to kind
of make sure that we're humble as we're looking
at these models and making sure that we don't
oversell them it's it's super important but uh
thank you so much once again we really appreciate
your your presentation thanks to everybody who
joined us and uh everyone have a have a wonderful
weekend try to stay out of the snow see ya next